well two things happened yesterday to
further reveal what we already knew
about big tech and big media and how
they conspire to censor and manipulate
the public the first was a major
announcement from youtube
the company announced it would be
removing any videos that allege
widespread voter fraud you're not
allowed to go on youtube and express the
opinion
that the election was stolen youtube has
made an editorial decision
which it would have every right to do if
it was a publisher
publishers make editorial decisions all
the time the daily wire publishes lots
of content every day it can decide
what sort of content it wants to publish
what sort of opinions or viewpoints it
wants to put out there what sorts of
opinions it doesn't want to put out
there
the problem is that youtube just like
facebook and twitter
claims to be a platform not a publisher
it claims that it is merely
hosting the content merely providing a
home
for people to post content
its role is neutral it says that line
has
been clearly untenable for a while but
youtube's announced decision yesterday
completely blew their own previous
rationalizations apart
i listen to this statement from youtube
announcing the policy and tell me if it
doesn't sound exactly like a publisher
explaining you know its editorial
guidelines essentially here's what it
said
quote yesterday was the safe harbor
deadline for the u.s presidential
election and enough states have
certified their election results to
determine a president-elect given that
we will start removing any piece of
content uploaded today or anytime after
that misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or error
changed the outcome of the 2020 u.s
presidential election
in line with our approach towards
historical u.s presidential elections
for example we will remove videos
claiming that a presidential candidate
won the election due to widespread
software glitches or counting errors
we will begin enforcing this policy
policy today and will ramp it up in the
coming weeks
it doesn't matter what you think about
the voter fraud question
the point is that some people have the
opinion that the election was stolen
that there was fraud et cetera and if
youtube is a neutral platform then they
should be able to express that opinion
on it
yet it's not a neutral platform and that
is why
you may have noticed youtube has for the
past four years
played host to many many videos alleging
that donald trump stole the election in
2016
that he's not a legitimate president
that he's in cahoots with russia and so
on
i mean they said this is in line with
their historical approach to
presidential elections oh really
i went to youtube before the show
searched searched for just like two
seconds
and i found this video on youtube watch
i believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did and i
take responsibility for those parts of
it that i should but jane it was like
applying for a job and getting 66
million
letters of recommendation and losing to
a corrupt human tornado and so i know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level
i don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened but clearly we
know
a lot and are learning more every day
and history will probably sort it all
out
so of course he's obsessed with me and i
believe
that it's a guilty conscience in so much
as he has a conscience
a corrupt human tornado right if donald
trump is a corrupt human tornado then
hillary clinton is the whole damn
hurricane um so that's that's
that's speaking of not having a
conscience but conscience but
um that sounds what you just heard there
sounds an
awful lot like hillary clinton alleging
that trump stole the election if trump
is an illegitimate president
that would mean that he won the election
by fraud of some kind
if he won the election legitimately then
he's a legitimate president
that's what hillary clinton is claiming
here um it's what she's claimed
repeatedly over the past four years is
what the media has claimed the democrats
have claimed
and yet their videos remain up their
posts have not been taken down
they're not censored so always remember
this very few of the people
currently ringing their hands about
trump undermining the integrity of our
election
by claiming fraud actually have the
moral authority
or credibility to be outraged about it
almost all of them
have been doing exactly the same thing
relentlessly for years
and this is just one example of
censorship and manipulation by
big tech and big media to come out of
yesterday here's the other
if you go to google right now type in
the words hunter biden
an amazing thing will happen now you
recall that up until this moment
if you typed in hunter biden you would
uh
you would find mostly a bunch of
articles from mainstream media sources
telling us that all the stuff about
hunter biden
and biden family corruption was a bunch
of fake news
you find fact checkers debunking it
articles explaining why the whole thing
is
really nothing at all and if you went to
twitter or facebook you'd find
not much about hunter biden at all
because most of the subjects
uh you know were most of the the posts
on that subject were taken down
in the most massive and coordinated
censorship campaign we'd ever seen
up to that point now youtube is going to
try to give it a run for its money
though but now today go to google type
in hunter biden
and you get tons of headlines posted
just today or last night saying stuff
like this here are some examples
federal criminal investigation into
hunter biden focuses on his business
dealings in china
justice department's interests and
hunter biden covered more than taxes
joe biden's son hunter biden under
federal investigation for tax case
hunter biden tax affairs under federal
investigation links to china funds
emerge
sources say hunter biden tax probe
examining chinese business dealings
and on and on now what happened
i'm old enough to remember four weeks
ago when the hunter biden story was fake
news
so fake that twitter had to ban you if
you talked about it
now here's what a cnn article and
they're one of the headlines i mentioned
before
but a cnn article published this morning
this is what they this is this is their
report they say
quote after going quiet in the months
before the election federal authorities
are now actively investigating the
business dealings of hunter biden a
person with knowledge of the probe said
his father president-elect joe biden is
not implicated
now that the election is over the
investigation is entering a new face
federal prosecutors in delaware working
with the irs criminal investigation
agency and the fbi are taking overt
steps such as issuing subpoenas and
seeking interviews
activity investigation had gone had gone
covert in recent months due to justice
apartment guidelines
prohibiting overt actions that could
affect an election the person said
it then goes on to say quote
investigators have been examining
multiple financial issues including
whether hunter biden
and his associates violated tax and
money laundering laws in business
dealings in foreign countries
principally china according to two
people briefed on the probe
oh so in other words the original report
from new york post which was banned on
twitter
and condemned or ignored by outlets like
cnn was correct
the justice department just didn't want
to confirm it because they didn't want
to
effect an election but they didn't want
to affect it how
with the truth what they're telling us
is that
they were afraid the truth might
influence our vote so they decided not
to tell us the truth
to me that sounds an awful lot like
affecting an election
if you're going to affect an election
with the truth or not the truth
better to affect it with the truth in
fact elections are supposed to be
affected by the truth of course
with or without the justice department
though the evidence of hunter biden's
corruption was clear as day
the new york post was trying to tell us
about it it's just that they were
prevented from doing so
sam stein of the daily beast posted a
link to an article today
and writes quote evidence of a mundering
money laundering probe into hunter biden
was apparent in the markings on a series
of documents that were made public
but went largely unnoticed in the days
leading up to the november election
largely unnoticed sam huh why is that
you're in the news media isn't it your
job to
notice these things and make sure
everyone else notices them
it's clear now just as it was clear all
along that the hunter biden story is
real was always real
the corruption in the biden family goes
deep um
but there was a conspiracy yes an actual
conspiracy
to hide and cover up this information so
as to ensure that biden is elected
now the election is over there they'll
let the floodgates open no need to hold
back the river now
they already got the guy they wanted
what the media
and big tech have done here may not
qualify as
election fraud in the legal sense and if
it did i guess i wouldn't be allowed to
say it without this show getting removed
from youtube
but this is certainly a form of meddling
of interfering of
undermining our election and this is the
form of election interference
that will be i think our biggest
obstacle in the future forget about
rigging ballots
they don't need to rig the ballots if
they can first rig the dissemination and
spread of information
if they can manipulate the public into
filling out the ballots how they want
that's all they need to do and that's
their game now
and our republic will suffer because of
it
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated